foreign
and welcome back to our Channel today we
have an exciting topic to discuss what
is devsec Ops it's a term that's been
gaining a lot of attention in the world
of software development and cyber
security
in this video we'll delve into what
devsecopes is all about its importance
and how it can revolutionize the way we
build and secure our applications so
let's Dive Right In but before that do
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the Bell icon for more interesting
videos like this so if you're ready to
embrace this exciting career path look
no further than simply learns Caltech
postgraduate program in devops this
comprehensive program will equip you
with the knowledge and skills needed to
master the day of principles tools and
practices dive deep into
containerization orchestration and
automation Frameworks like Docker
kubernetes and gen kits gain hands-on
experience with Cloud platforms and
learn how to Leverage The Power of
infrastructure as code don't miss out on
this chance to transform your career and
become an invaluable asset to any
organization click the link in the
description to discover more about this
day offs course so first thing first
what exactly is dead SEC Ops well it's a
combination of three key Concepts
development security and operations
dead SEC orbs is an approach that
integrates security practices and
processes into the entire software
development life cycle right from the
planning and coding stages to testing
deployment and ongoing operations
it aims to ensure that security is not
an afterthought but rather than integral
part of the development process
now you might be wondering why we need
devsec Ops in the first place
well in today's interconnected World
cyber threats are constantly evolving
and traditional security measures are
often not enough
with the rapid pace of software
development and deployment organizations
need to prioritize security without
slowing down the development process and
that's where devsecops comes into play
well one of the core principles of
devsec Ops is Shifting security left it
means bringing security considerations
earlier in the development cycle
enabling developers to identify and
address potential security
vulnerabilities as the right code
by doing so we can catch security issues
early on reducing the risk of
introducing vulnerabilities into the
final product
but how exactly does devsec Ops work
let's break it down into four main
pillars collaboration automation
continuous security and monitoring the
first pillar is collaboration
now devsec Ox encourages collaboration
and communication between development
teams security teams and operations
teams
by breaking down silos and fostering a
culture of shared responsibility
organizations can ensure that security
is everyone's concern not just a
separate team's responsibility
the second pillar is automation
automation plays a crucial role in
devsec Ops by enabling organizations to
streamline security processes and make
them more efficient
tasks such as code analysis
vulnerability scanning and compliance
checks can be automated allowing teams
to focus on higher value activities and
reducing the chances of human error
next we have continuous security Now
defsecops emphasizes the need for
continuous security testing throughout
the development life cycle
it involves integrating security testing
into the cicd pipeline conducting
regular vulnerability assessments and
leveraging tools that can detect and
remediate security issues in real time
by continuously monitoring and
addressing security concerns
organizations can ensure that their
applications remain secure and resilient
lastly we have monitoring now deadsec
Ops promotes the use of robust
monitoring and logging mechanisms to
gain visibility into application
behavior and potential security
incidents
by closely monitoring applications
performance logs and security events
organizations can quickly detect and
respond to any security breaches or
anomalies minimizing the impact and
reducing the time to remedition
so now that we understand the core
principles of deadsec orbs let's talk
about the benefits it offers
firstly devsecops helps organizations
reduce security Risk by addressing
vulnerabilities early in the development
process by integrating security into
every stage of the software development
life cycle organizations can
significantly reduce the chances of
security breaches and data leaks
secondly devsec Ops promotes faster and
more efficient software development by
automating security processes and
fostering collaboration developers can
focus on delivering high quality code
while securing concerns are handled in
parallel this leads to Shorter
development cycles and faster time to
Market
thirdly devsecops improves the overall
quality of software
repeat thirdly devsec Ops improves the
overall quality of software with
continuous security testing and
monitoring organizations can proactively
identify and fix software flaws ensuring
a more robust and resilient application
by building security into the
development process organizations can
establish a strong Foundation of trust
with their users
and lastly desec orbs encourages a
culture of shared responsibility and
collaboration within organizations
developers Security Professionals and
operations teams work together towards a
common goal delivering secure and
Reliable Software
now this collaborative approach Fosters
knowledge sharing enhances communication
and strengthens the overall security
posture of the organization
so now the question arises how can you
adopt devsec Ops in your organization
well it starts with the cultural shift
embrace the mindset that Securities
everyone's responsibility first a
collaboration and communication between
teams educate your developers about
secure coding practices and provide them
with the necessary tools and training to
identify and address security issues
additionally leverage Automation and
devsec Ops tools to streamline your
security processes integrate security
testing into your CI CD Pipeline and
make sure of vulnerability scanning and
code analysis tools to catch security
flows early on remember devsecops is an
ongoing Journey it requires continuous
learning adaptation and Improvement
stay updated with the latest security
Trends and best practices and regularly
assess and enhance your security
measures
so technically to wrap up devsecups is a
game changer in the world of software
development and cyber security
by integrating security into every
aspect of the development process
organizations can build and deliver
secure reliable and resilient
applications
so it's time to embrace the power of
devsec Ops and create a secure future
for our Digital World here's an
inspiring success story from our
satisfied Learners who have propelled
their career with devops the future of
software development is here and it's
waiting for you to embrace it so let's
get started with it I was really
impressed by how many job interviews I
landed after I added a certification to
my portfolio and now I am earning 40
more than my previous job I started my
It Journey with Accenture three years
ago I joined there as a cloud architect
there I worked with AWS and Azure
Technologies I was anyway looking for
higher paying job and devops seem the
right career choice so I decided to go
with the postgraduate program in devops
in collaboration with Caltech ctme the
course was divided into modules
and we had assignments for each module
it didn't only boost my career but also
my confidence well
that to hit the like button and
subscribe to our YouTube channel for
more exciting content and if you have
any questions related to this topic then
please feel free to ask away in our
comment section below our team will
reach out to you as soon as possible
thank you and keep learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign